[Music]
on the 5th of february 1952 princess
elizabeth attended a service at some
phillips church in the foothills of
mount kenya
she didn't know it then of course but
within hours her life would change
completely early the following morning
her father king george died and she
became the queen
as we continue to remember
our
queen
the pulpit was a gift from her and the
duke of edinburgh and her coat of arms
still hangs in the church today after
her coronation the queen sent a section
of the carpet that lay in westminster
abbey that day to this small rural
church which must have had special
memories for her
she is part of the congregation in the
records she is there and part of your
family she's sort of our family that is
part of our family and
being part of our family she is part of
us and
we are also mourning the
her death and we also
part of the
part of the family that is money
she spent her final evening as a
princess at treetops lodge in the peace
and quiet of aberdeen national park
surrounded by wildlife and sleeping in a
tree house on the edge of a watering
hole
the treehouse was burnt down a few years
later by the mao mao during the
uprisings against british rule but the
hotel was rebuilt
and your father cooked for her
my father cooked lunch for her and she
was telling us stories how she was
asking the question very juvia she was
making fun
oh the nicest fair food the night then
the food
the food was very nice they make jokes
hey because we have just get it from the
farm right now
that is oh nice i will come back again a
chicken chicken burger
yeah sure it was a privilege anyway
a handwritten note lists the animals
they saw during their stay water buck
baboon elephants
and bull rhinos fighting in the morning
the princess elizabeth swede is now the
hotel's jewel in the crown
memories of her stay a part of the
history of this place
i felt i we have lost someone that
had loved kenya and
it's
and treat approach as well
because this is the home of the loyal
farmers so many people say this is her
hotel
if you go out and ask people you said
that's queen's hotel
when princess elizabeth heard the news
of her father's death she cut the royal
visit short and rushed back to london
but she returned to treetops lodge in
1983 to see the animals and the staff
and spend time in the place where she
enjoyed the final hours before her life
changed forever aleister bunker sky news
in kenya